Hello, everybody.
Hello, hello.
My god, Doki, what happened?
Like, I'm so tired.
I'm so tired.
I just woke up from a nap.
Guys, guys, is it obvious that I just woke up?
up can you tell can can you guys tell that I just woke up
from a nap what did I it's been a long day um so um I might
have fucked up I might have dream queued till six in the
morning yesterday And then I had a paddle at 10.30.
And then I chugged down half a cup of coffee for it.
And I crashed out right after.
Because I won, though.
I won a lot.
Okay.
It still do.
Okay, I won, but I felt nothing.
So technically.
It's still doom queue.
My alt account is now...
My alt account is now the same rank as my main, which is
pretty...
Which is...
I won like 10 games or something.
I don't know.
I just know I won 10 plus...
More than 10 games.
So it's now like one game away from Celestia 1, which is top
500.
So...
it's but i felt nothing i felt it was i just kept winning i
don't know i also had someone flame me too okay i can tell
you guys i um it's okay like i drank i like chugged out half
a coffee and i was okay but you know how like when you chug
when you like chug down coffee and then you have the biggest
crash ever right after so that's what happened to me and
that's why i'm so right now because I took a nap right after
everything was done and I was like I can't I legitimately
didn't want to play any games today I thank you for the
magenta soup but thank you thank you ify dokey is the best
dokey I need I needed to I legitimately I remember when my
my oh she used to play video games what happened to her
remember when you used to be a gamer now all you do is watch
football and talk you don't even game anymore you remember
when toky bird was a gamer i don't i don't even remember the
last time she played a real game i back in my day toky used
to dream video games
She just hopped stream back in the good ye old days Um
Sherry lost my train I'm sorry I'm so tired Anyway yeah but
like I literally just I just didn't feel like gaming today I
just didn't feel like I just wanted to talk I wanted to
chill I wanted to hang out Also help me let's order some
food I need I didn't eat a lot today I just like I ordered
some egg bites with my coffee because I had to add something
in my stomach.
I'm not hungry.
I don't know.
And I just been, like, stressed and tired.
So, like, but now, like, my stomach is, like, it's, like, a
little stomach ache because my stomach's like, I will slowly
digest itself.
Like, my stomach is just like, I will eat myself if you
don't get put food in me right now.
Like, well, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
55 hamburgers thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you uh i am not ordering well i'm in canada so the diarrhea
parasite is not gonna hurt me um unless like i don't know
they import like lettuce from america um yeah fast way to
lose weight though um not great uh apparently good i was
like okay to be fair i asked about it i i like not asked
about it but like i i was like i was about you know I was
like it's not that bad you know at least you don't die from
diarrhea like from diarrhea and then they're like because
you know I'm in Canada like so I was just like I don't know
too much about it other than the fact that it's a diarrhea
parasite but then you're like Doki it's explosive diarrhea
parasite people have been hospitalized already I was like oh
my God.
I thought you were just pooping.
That's what's dysentery.
It's dysentery.
Like, order 55 Benjamin toast.
Lise, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I was like, oh my God.
People are in the hospital?
I thought it was just, you're just pooping.
I was like, well, good, at least like you're losing weight,
you know.
I was like, oh, I was just, I was just thinking, hey, at
least you're losing some weight on the other hand.
It can't all be that bad.
It's deadly.
No, it's pooping with consequences.
Yeah.
I was like, oh, that's why people are very, very scared
right now.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
Go-Keybird, the Pittsburgh organization for order and
prosperity has declared your UPA's most wanted for comparing
our Italian sandwich train to British food.
We do not take transgression lightly.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
All right.
I'm here to clear my name.
I was also going to talk about this.
So I was at TekkoCon, not off guy today.
It was a really great convention.
Apparently, it was so cool meeting a lot of dragoons.
TekkoCon and it is at Pittsburgh and I think the really cool
thing is that it's a very um I guess like a frequent
well-known convention for a lot of locals there because I
met Dragon was like I was like asking me how long you guys
have been going to TekkoCon and they're like it's been my
seventh year or like seven year going to this convention so
I was so surprised to see you and I was like yeah like you
know I love I you know I loved like doing new conventions
and stuff and like um because like I uh the off guy has a
role where they don't uh where they every year they new
vtubers so they can't have a vtuber that shows up uh consent
like back to back um so i was just like all right maybe i
won't try a teko con i do and then and then and then i did i
had the wildcard club thing come up as well so now i was
just like oh what a cool like you know i i was like oh okay
like it all work it all works out like even though it wasn't
a guest at off guy um i still have a panel at off guy
because of the wildcard club stuff like i still have a
presence there so i was wanted to be guests at another
convention and I chose TekkoCon.
Because it's also on the other side.
It's on East Coast as well.
So the East Coast goons get a little treat.
Anyway, so I thought it was, I'm going to East and West
Coast back to back.
I thought it was really cool because there were drag goons
that have been going to this convention.
Like there was one that was like the ninth year anniversary.
Some bro goons were like, yeah, this is our ninth
anniversary going to this convention.
And I was like, oh my God.
What are you guys gonna do if we're 10th year?
Are you gonna do anything special?
And I wanna say, are you gonna get, are you gonna propose?
Like, I'm fine.
I held myself in because they only had four minutes.
So I didn't wanna, I didn't wanna like go into that type of
tangent because we only had four minutes to talk to each
other.
Oh, are you gonna do anything special for your 10th
anniversary, guys?
It's tough.
Anyway.
You know, it's a joke.
obviously.
But I thought it was really cool.
It was like, I didn't realize it was such a big local
convention there at Pittsburgh, where it was all of like,
you know, it was like a tradition to go to the Teku Khan.
Totally reformed.
I'm reformed, guys.
Anyway, so during my panel, one of the dragons at the panel
was telling us about this particular sandwich.
Sorry, I got off track there.
I got into a tangent, what I was actually trying to say.
And they're talking about, I'll show this to you guys.
They're talking about the sandwich.
I think it's called the Prementi Brothers Sandwich.
And I was just like, all right, cool.
I was like, you know, I was like, oh, like a Philly sandwich
or some shit.
Like, you know, like stuff like that.
And then so I was like, oh, that's cool.
What's in it?
So in a Prementi Brothers Sandwich, for those who don't
know, who never been the and never had the sandwich.
It is a...
It is a sandwich where the contents of it is fries, colesal,
and vinegar.
And when I saw this picture, I was like, if this is...
if your signature sandwich is basically Something you think
you'll find in the United Kingdom.
I don't think you would want that.
I...
I was like, bro, if your sandwich is something I could get
in England, I think you guys better invite...
I think that you guys should invent a better sandwich.
So the left side, the left side is a chip buddy.
And the right side is the Promen- This is a chip buddy that
you can get in England with the British.
And the right side is the Americanized version of that.
Don't tell them I said that.
It's called the Promenty Brothers, which is also something
you can get.
And, which is a signature sandwich in Pittsburgh.
They had just a very compact sandwich.
So, so we do not clean.
So, um, so that's why.
So, I, that's why I was just like, guys.
say.
That's what they, that's what they were talking about about
their sandwich, and I was just like, guys, I don't think you
want your sandwich to look like something I could get in
England.
Spider, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
When the British said, burn the witch, this is the witch
they meant.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
um anya thank you the super chat thank you thank you hey
dokey i was a dragon who asked for the con specific story at
the panel i just want to say thank you for giving me a
reason come on teko it's my first time to you it's been
really great thank you the magenta super thank you thank you
i'm glad you've been you enjoying teko con i hope you come
to more teko cons in the future and like make you a
tradition as well uh make me a lot of other i hope you met a
lot of other dragons there I don't have to thank you again
for the magenta soup, but thank you.
Yes, I finally got asked about the con-specific story.
And then at first, I legitimately forgot what the convention
story is.
For the, okay, this is just, I can't say it.
I cannot say this.
If you're ever at a convention and I do a Q&A, and you've
never heard about the con-exclusive story, make sure to ask
it during the Q&A.
And then you will be in the exclusive club of dragoons
who've heard, it's always the same one.
Yes.
It's always the same one.
And just make sure you line up, like, get a chance to ask me
at the Q&A panels.
And you'll get to join the exclusive club of Dragoons who
know the convention exclusive story, which I cannot tell on
a public stream.
No, it's not that.
It's just...
It's just a story that I legitimately cannot tell in a
public stream So that it's on the internet forever
For very good reasons When you're in the club People who are
in the club Knows why
People who are in the club Know why this is a convention
exclusive story The forbidden story um yeah we take your
secret to the grave um so um so i literally haven't told a
story for like for the longest time so because like you know
so because like i haven't i think i haven't done like an q a
in a while um yeah and so like i i i was like oh give me a
sec i might have to YouTube myself because I know like maybe
there was people sometimes record my convention panel so I
was like maybe I can find it somewhere but I couldn't
remember which convention and I said one word because I was
like the only thing I remember about the convention story
about the convention exclusive story is that somehow related
to this thing and I said it out loud and I like light bulb
in my head I instantly remembered the story I because I
remember the reason why so bad because it's related to
something else and I said the word and then I was like that
story I remembered now I and only the dragons in the very
exclusive convention exclusive story knows what that keyword
is and that's the key word is what makes an exclusive
convention story um if you know you know yeah
Well, a cast, thank you for super chat.
Thank you.
Will that thing on the right come back to life?
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Factor.
Yeah, it's like a sleeper activation word.
It ain't better than the Philly cheesecake.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Only the keyword.
When you know, you know why.
All right, let's see, let me see, I wrote it down on this,
oh yeah, so that's what, I'm awake now, I, see, I told you,
it takes a, it takes a while, uh, it takes a while for my
body and brain to catch up with me, it's like starting a
car, starting it, like, starting a very old car, right now,
it's like, but I'm awake now, I'm a lot more awake, I
literally woke up at like, 655 um but we're okay now um
michael jackson thank you oh my god sad theme i would love
to collaborate with a hologram of michael jackson uh we
should imagine that like the most famous uh singer the most
famous pop singer in the world well i mean he still is like
his super bold like his autobiography movie apparently what
did really really well um i think it was super chat thank
thank you what's i'm gonna say uh the king of pop yeah um
all right i wrote down some stuff oh yeah okay so i know a
lot of dragons a lot of vtuber fans are also at offkai and a
lot of vtubers too are at uh offkai right now um i hope
everyone's having a great time at offkai um i hope you guys
saw the lockers i also saw the pittsburgh goons the uh
offkai lockers too because like i know they were someone
asked about like the wildcard club project and i was like oh
here's a little exclusive uh because i didn't know if they
posted oh my gosh that's been super bratty today i don't
know why uh but like yeah anyway i did a little walk around
of the um of the booth at the wildcard club because today i
was gonna do i was just gonna walk around artist alley today
and i'm gonna pick him up today's really because i'm not i'm
not gaming or anything so i can pick him up give me a sec no
it's it was really bad today let me pick him up hey
never mind i went to pick him up and instantly ran away like
a bitch up um all right so what was it what gonna say okay i
really lost my train of thought guys i'm sorry i'm oh yeah
wildcard club um so i didn't know when if the the lockers
were already shown uh people who took the pictures yet like
i did not know i concept of time anymore that's like at that
do it like you know i haven't i don't usually i'm not
usually awake at 10 in the morning that's like that's like
if i woke up at for regular people it's like if i if they
woke up at 8 in the morning but 10 a.m is like my 8am but um
back like but i showed them uh some photos of the lockers my
locker so you know i don't want you guys to have fomo so
i'll tell give you guys i'll show you guys pictures of the
locker so the lockers um i think mine is the only one that
brought like a majority like it's all of my personal items
because some of the other girls lockers are decorated with
like they gave a list of it um they um for the lockers so
the concept is like oh like a glimpse inside like the
glimpse of your like a personality glimpse of your
personality through the lockers um so uh we were given a
document to list a bunch of stuff that reflects like our
like our hobbies our favorite fandoms um items we want in
the locker and everything so um i gave them my list but i
wanted to bring my own personal items as well.
To, you know, personalize, like, give, like, my own items
that I, like, that I actually own to be displayed at the
locker.
What I didn't realize is that the entire locker was
actually, is actually all items I actually own.
So everything you see in the locker is something I brought
from home, so, to the staff in Korea.
So I own all of it.
Like, it's not, like, stuff, it's not, none of it is, like,
things that I own.
are um except for the faker plushie the faker plushie they
bought that one because i wanted you know i wanted to bring
faker uh back home so they bought another cop they bought
another one just for the locker because i was like i want
faker plushie in there i my oshi my other oshi um see my
oshi is me and faker uh i only oshi people who know ball uh
joystick thank you super chat thank you thank you sub toky
um so i think the other girls um a lot of them is like stuff
that um the staff bought to from the list to customize their
locker but my locker like i said is all items i brought from
home that ashley owned and they're going to give it back to
me after the convention so all right let me show you guys i
was tempted to actually bring my i was tempted to bring my
uh daft punk uh gie manuel replica helmet as well but then
it was just it would have been too much work to bring it to
Korea so I unfortunately I didn't bring that to her display
maybe in the future if I do something like if I do a
convention that has like a display of like personal items
from a vtuber I would love to bring that to show you guys
because I have a lot of collectibles I love interesting
things I collect or own because I'm um I don't want to say
I'm a hoarder but I don't I've seen actual one point so like
um i know it's like just a random like fucked up fact about
myself um so i know what a hoarder house actually looks like
um so i so i'm like i've seen what a actual hoarder house
looks like so so i'm not a hoarder like but i own a lot of
interesting things because i when i see something
interesting or or funny or um or just like i don't know i
just like collect i just like owning it or collecting it
because i think it's like um i just i don't know it's just i
just i just like collecting things i i used to collect a lot
of bunch of random things like i used to be collector and
then something and then i jump between stuff a lot um just
anything that pipes my interest so um what was so funny
about the locker let me see if i can find the picture was uh
all right all right so this was the original picture uh they
sent us you might notice something so this was the original
i'll give you guys a quick uh
So, you might notice a lot of things in this locker.
The most important detail that you might see in that locker
is that Doki Prime has a shirt on.
And I was like, take that jacket off!
Like, let me see if I can find the direct quote.
I was like, I was like, ask them to remove the jacket.
and let her be naked.
I...
How dare...
Doki Prime must be freed like the day she was born.
How dare you censor Doki Prime?
Anyway, she's naked now.
They don't deserve clothes.
The genie...
So...
I was like, it's naked and free.
How dare they sally the sanctity of Doki Prime?
Yes, so they uncensored.
They uncensored Doki Prime for me.
In front of Faker.
Right next to Faker.
Ah, yes, my two Oshis.
Doki Prime as God intended.
hashtag free bird truly a wild card member i put the wild
and wild card
so um so like i said also the i was like wondering where the
fuck is my controller and i forgot i gave them my controller
in korea because i was like Where is, remember when I was
like, I don't know where the fuck's my controller is, guys.
I don't want to play with controller right now.
Because I legit don't know where I put it.
And I saw it in the locker.
Like they showed the picture of the locker to me.
And I saw it.
And I was like, that's where I put my controller.
Like yesterday, I was like, oh my god.
That's where it is.
I was like, no wonder can't fucking find it.
I...
I brought a lot of items.
You don't understand.
I brought a lot of items to the locker.
Like, it was entire...
I bought, like, half a suitcase.
Full of my personal...
Like, all the things I brought...
From my...
From my personal, like, you know, from...
Like, from home is in that locker.
Like, I own all of this, except for the Faker Plus She.
Because I didn't want to...
You know, I didn't want to...
uh that that faker plus share bought was i was bringing him
home like i had asked them if they could buy another another
um another one just for the locker right thank you thank you
thank you thank you all of it was yours even the yowie dogen
we should do a reading stream one day they was super chat
thank you thank you uh yes the sacred text all right let me
just give you guys a close-up of all of this the the sacred
text we'll do this one by one i'll explain each item one by
one so if you must know my what i have in each locker i
shall explain every item in here one by one
top i didn't actually let me get recent photo i'm gonna grab
going for my photo i'm gonna grab something grab one from uh
the internet uh let's see let me grab one from the internet
i'm pretty sure someone took like a close-up of just my
locker in the front position um so let me check real quick
uh luckily there is a hashtag the wildcard club someone must
have posted also i thought it was I talked about it when I
was like there doing like a little uh walkthrough of the
booth I I saw photos of it and I don't think that was
intentional um but I thought it was really funny I'm sorry
if like by the way the staff that works at the wildcard club
they watch most of our streams so I'm
I'm sorry.
They might be busy right now.
But if you guys seen the setup of the wildcard club, there's
one where it's a couch.
And then the back, it's a white couch, by the way.
It's a white couch.
And the back is all four of us, like the standees in the
back.
And then when my staff...
My staff, my personal staff, my management staff, was taking
me around.
It was taking you out to show me the booth because I said I
was too tired.
I can just look at the booth and I saw it.
I told them, OK, I don't think this is intentional, but I
think it's really funny because I've been seeing pictures of
this couch and it looked like that couch meme with the guys
in the back.
No, and then my event staff was like, I know that meme.
And then you mean this one?
And she sat on the couch and did the girl's pose.
And she did the pose.
And I was like, yes, that meme.
I'm gonna see, I'm gonna find a picture of the empty couch.
I'm sure someone sent, someone posted a picture of the couch
itself empty.
And I'll show you guys what I mean, because I don't want to,
I'm, I don't want to like embarrass anybody that, um, that
took a picture of the couch, um, that took a picture of the
couch sitting on it.
Like, I don't want to, I don't want to expose anybody.
Surely, surely someone took a picture of this couch.
couch without sitting on it.
Surely.
I'm looking right now.
Thank you a lot for using my art in the thumbnail, Doki.
I can't believe I missed TekuCon was literally in Pittsburgh
recently.
For every W, there must be an equal in ops.
No!
Maybe next time.
Maybe next time I'll come back to I'll come back to
Pittsburgh.
But thank you so much for drawing the beautiful artwork for
the thumbnail.
I really appreciate all the artists who contribute their art
and their own free time.
so much and i this is like one little things i can do to
show my appreciation to all the fan artists who draw me is
such amazing artwork and maybe next time we'll meet amazing
in super chat thank you thank you all right so um um i know
you're like talk about the items but this is very important
i'm gonna show you guys what i mean for those who didn't see
the photos but this
why I thought do you see the the vision do you see do you
see what I mean when I say the way it's all positioned makes
me think about look how judy i see it i do i do indeed see
the vision i when i saw the pic the first that was the first
time when i saw the pictures coming out i i wish i was like
My event staff, when I mentioned it, my event staff was
like, I know that meme and sat on it and did the pose.
Yeah.
Um.
Anyway, all right.
Back to the items in the locker.
So as you guys can see, uh, oh, wait, I was that, sorry.
I was trying.
I'm trying to find a close-up of the locker.
I always forget.
I was trying.
And my whole goal was to find the close-up of my locker.
Let me see if I can actually find it.
The wild, that one, the wild club.
There was a typo for the club, guys.
It's just a little typo.
Kids, thank you, the super chat, thank you, thank you.
I'm still trying to find, like, a better photo of the items
in there.
Someone must have taken, like, a front view.
Okay, there.
Yeah, this one is more actually no there should be a more
front view Oh, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Pass the controller, bro Let me in coach.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Someone must have posted a photo Of just my locker or just
the front view of my locker so I give you guys a better if
not If not, we'll just go with The this photo that I have um
like small close-ups of it but i need one where it's like
front view and it's entire oh you know i'll use this one i'm
gonna use this one only because um dokey prime is naked um
let me see um tech welcome to tomato farm welcome welcome um
i like how that was the story that was like i should join
her membership
meme i'll with her i bro bro i fuck with this girl i need to
join those memberships right
she knows ball that guy knows ball okay all right let's try
this is a better photo just because Doki Prime is naked.
It's like a similar angle, but because she is naked, it's a
better photo.
Alright.
See?
It's like, as...
Oh yeah, also here's the replica of the shirt I wore in the
in the key visual, which we will be sent after the
convention only because they made one... By the time they
finished the second version, it was sent to us before the
convention but um because uh they uh they only were able to
make one in time they weren't able to send the second one um
in time to us before the convention so uh we'll get it after
because the ones that are at off guy right now you have a
chance to win the raffle for the shirt if you're at off guy
uh like the customized one you can buy the shirt itself but
this is like customized shirts that are each of us have um
it do be like that tech thank you with a super chat thank
you thank you all right so i'll go through each item so um
um for this one the first the top layer the top uh top the
top part it is dokey prime baker and at the very back i i
actually i brought this i brought this to korea like i said
like each item in that locker except for a baker um is
everything that i brought that's from home.
So I touched all of those items.
You can get DNA to clone a dogey braid if you want.
So it's all from my personal collection.
Anyway, so in the back, that is the, that is the Street
Fighter autograph that I got from the director of Street
Fighter.
So that is, copy i didn't bring the photocopy of it i didn't
bring like a copy of it version of it there's only one
there's only one autograph of this that i have and it's i
brought it up to korea so i could display it and have you
dragoons who are at off kai see it in person so people who
are there at off kai is the actual um uh autograph i got
from the director of street fighter that was where he drew
Honda for me personally um I didn't ask for it I just asked
for an autograph and she drew a custom Honda uh artwork uh
addressed to me and it's the authentic version there's only
one of one which I own and people that off Kai um people at
off Kai yes from Taka it's from Taka people at off Kai can
see it up close um at the booth so um so it's just a little
fun experience goons there because this is why i love the
idea of the lockers i love the idea of the lockers because i
was like i always talk about all these stories about all the
ridiculous items i own and all the cool stuff i own at home
and um and i was just like oh my god like this is the first
time i can actually show you guys some of these items that i
always told random stories about and you see it in person
too or like some of the stuff that i show you guys like you
know photos i show on stream and everything that people at
alfcai can actually see in person and be like this is the
item she she talked about yeah yeah these are the items
related to the stories that she's talking about and
everything oh my god there's dokey prime this is the dirty
dokey prime too the first original Doki Prime.
I didn't bring any of the copies because you know how um we
had three Doki I don't know it was our three or four Doki
Primes um because like one was the original first draft the
Doki Prime and then like I at we you know you got I was
planning on auctioning the other cop inferior copies uh like
in the future for charity I was thinking of auctioning the
inferior like two or three more of Dokey Primes somewhere in
my room.
But this one, this is the original first draft.
The very first Dokey Prime.
She is the original.
That's there at the lockers.
All right.
And then the next one, it's not official Funko Pop.
But this was at Phantom Thief.
During the Phantom Thief concert, the staff for the Phantom
Thief concert, the concert organizers, oh she sparks when we
first women and i first met them um they gifted me a
customized funko pop uh i think like oh my god was it like
two years ago oh my gosh i yeah it's two years ago sorry
that is so bratty today um and it uh they got me a
customized funko pop of me basically um as a gift and i was
was such a very thoughtful gift and i know i always joke
about funko pops i don't think it'll ever be a reality
because they are essentially bankrupt uh hey i can't give
him a charity gave him a treat yeah he's been so what what
no no no okay i'll tell you a story why he's been i'll tell
you what how he's been super i turned around he started
barking um so um the reason why i'm saying that he's been
really bratty today is that um he was barking during my meet
and greet he was actually being he was actually very i'm
gonna put him on i'm gonna put him on my bed i'm gonna give
him bedtime give me a sec all
right he gets to he gets to have the comfort of my very
comfy bed anyway he gets what he wants i know today he's
been really bad okay so uh it's just been uh no it is a
reward for i'm i know i'm sorry but like i don't know what
to do right now because
Sorry, you was super chat thinking, thank you.
Ah, the fossilized remains of Tokey Prime, aka Tokey Hurek.
This is a sight to behold.
Sorry, you was super chat thinking that he has trained me
very well.
Um, but like, during meet and greet, like, uh, it was like,
that's when he started ripping it.
Like, he started ulting.
Um, he started ulting.
In the middle, like, there was just like, we were almost
done with meet and greets.
And in the middle of one of the meeting greets, he just
started alting.
And it was so loud.
And I was like, I'm so sorry.
I was like, stop the timer.
Because like, you know, they paid to, it was a lottery too.
It was a lottery and they paid to see me.
They paid, like, they paid to see me.
So I was just like, please stop the timer.
Because like, I had to give him a treat.
Yeah, and it was so loud, too.
loud and I was like I'm so sorry please stop the timer so
here you got a treat and then and then um during uh the I
did a little tour slash I had had a little tour because
today I was doing an artist alley thing today okay I need to
keep my door open it's very hot in my room today I don't
know why um but today um he we had to do uh I was walk
around time because I was like okay um it I was so tired so
we're rescheduling that for another day um and uh we're
rescheduling it to Sunday and so um I was so tired already
and I don't didn't think I could do a very long walk around
of the artist alley today just because like I was just super
exhausted and tired um after so um like I my if you guys for
people who did see me at off guide I looked like this
basically and it was
I came out looking like this with the eye bags and
everything so and then I was touring the wildcard club and
then the staff there was like I think I was like the first
one that did a virtual tour at the booth at that time so
they're like oh can we have an interview like where you talk
about seeing the lockers for the first time.
And I was joking around.
I was like, oh my God, guys.
Look at these lockers.
Oh my God.
They even have a locker of my Oshi, Doki Bird.
I heard she's really cool.
So you should join the club.
And then like he was fine.
He didn't say anything.
And then they wanted to do another interview where I was
like, join the wildcard club.
At the wall, like one of the deck walls.
During like another section And then I was trying to say I
was like join the wildcard club guys Like and then that just
started alting And he's like And it was so loud And so like
I don't know if they're ever I don't know if they're gonna
put that clip in I don't know if they're gonna post that
clip on the social media Or anything But you could just hear
dad fucking Like barking so loud in the background like a
small clip for the staff at the wildcard club uh booth and
he's just like yeah he was ready and i was just like we had
one take by the way we because he would not stop he would he
would not stop and he was like my door was closed but i have
a glass door so there's a glass window not like a door made
of glass but it's like a wood door but there's a glass
window in the middle the door from the bottom to the middle
like from the bottom to the top there's like a glass window
so you could look in and just started fucking ripping it
like and then and then you know after the small um the the
filming of like the small interview filming or whatever the
clip uh the the clip that the staff there wanted to film um
i told like the tour was over and i told my staff like i'm
gonna go now i want to take a nap before i stream and and i
wanted to push the stream a hours later for so i could just
yap to you guys and he was not hungry he i fed him he's been
fed he was walked already and he got a treat in the moment
and he was still barking by the way he's still barking once
telling my staff i was ready to leave i was i was like all
right i was thank you for i'll see you guys on sunday um
thanks for giving me a tour blah blah you know all you know
the all the usual stuff and we're like hey we're like bye
bye and hang up i stopped talking i looked at the window
like by the way while i was saying bye was still barking i
looked at the glass window he looked at me and he walked
away that little that
he looked i looked at him he looked at me He noticed I
stopped talking He turned around And walked away Back to my
bedroom And went back to sleep
That fucking bitch That little brat He fucking Rage hated
Mission Mission accomplished I was like Oh you're done like
he is he is he is a little shit right there like he
literally stopped barking the moment i left the call
my job here is done
Because I was like, what do you want?
I gave you everything.
And this is what he wanted.
I was like, you got your treat.
You got fed already.
You had your walkies before I did the tour.
And so I was like, what do you want?
You're like, what do you want from me?
You sleep all day.
There's no reason for you to want more sleep.
You literally sleep.
all day like like how could you want more sleep like um um
send me swords thank you for the super chat thank you thank
you oh my god don't you don't get to yapp if you're
exhausted go to sleep thank you for the super chat thank you
thank you don't worry i'll go go take uh i'll go sleep uh
after the stream after i eat uh but thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you Sir, thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
That is too smart for his own good.
He's an evil genius in a dog's body and vengeful.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
So, so, yeah, no, that's why I was like, what do you want?
You already, you, he has had dinner already.
I fed him dinner before this stream.
Cause I, I knew, I knew he was, I should have, I should have
saved it.
I should have saved the food when he started barking because
that would, that buys me time.
that that buys me time i should have saved it i should have
fed him when he started barking during the stream because at
least they would buy me a bunch of time
yeah i popped my ult too early um anyway all right next item
all right all right for this one that that's the controller
oh not only is there's two controllers in one is the the
customized dokey brick controller which you can still get by
the way i know i haven't advertised it in a while um let me
say i remember uh i don't i don't remember the website it's
been a while so let me let me see if i google it and if it
shows up oh here it is for those who want to get the exact
controller i own um this is it uh yes it is back um a while
thank you super chat back in the uh i think it's this one
you have to go scroll down you build your own um yes it was
void gaming so this is the exact uh version that i have um
that was sent to me so uh and this was like the the very
first one i believe so um anyway uh they brought it back
they did a restock of it and i forgot to talk about it
because there was just so many things going on but they did
bring one of them and um and anyway so uh that's where it
went i was literally like i was literally like where the
fuck is my controller like at home because i was like trying
to play games and literally because it was a while since i
went to korea so i was legitimately like you know post korea
i was like where's my controller how am i supposed to play
games when i don't know where my controller is and i was
like yes the controller is still being sold so so so that
was why I've been playing on I was playing on mouse and
keyboard for a long time for like games that are normally on
controller because legitimately don't remember like I
literally forgot that I gave my controller the staff so I
was just like oh man I don't even know where I put my
controller like so so yesterday i saw the photo of the
locker i was like that's where my controller is oh my i
solved the mystery i don't have to clean my apartment to
find yeah anyway
in the back you might notice another um controller there and
that was the say the first say jam slam I was in where we
won with the um where we won in Tekken um with and it from
uh from the say jam slam they um for winning first place
they gave uh one of the prizes yes the say jam controller uh
team BP and to team Brawl Pro and there uh in the back was
the was the controller they gifted us the leverless say jam
slam controller so um so that's where where doking was born
so that's what it is um i found it like um i don't use that
controller when i play fighting games um just because you
know it was a it's considered one of my trophies slash
prizes i got from winning my first say jam slam um playing
Tekken for the first time and uh doing the impossible and
beating SK like no one believed in me and beating SK I don't
like honestly like it felt like um like if there was a
polymarket bet and like um it felt like um someone paid uh
someone had a paid for the bet for me to win and then they
would like it was like the biggest upset in tournament
because no one believed not even me I knew I thought I
thought it was like I was just there like to like be fodder
uh yeah it would like yeah it would have been an actual
scandal if money was involved yeah the rock paper scissors
of me sk and esam because sk beat esam and i lost the e like
everybody lost esam except for sk like sk was the first
person to ever beat esam and you guys don't know who esam is
he is a really i don't know i know i person didn't really
know who esam was until they told me who esam was but he's
like a really uh he is a smash like he's a smash bros uh
fighting game player so like he came in already knowing what
fighting games are yeah and and so like and everyone was
like oh my god sk finally be finally was the first person to
be east at the entire tournament and then i had to fight her
next uh yeah and i had to fight her next so obviously like
the odds were very Against me if there was like an actual
poly market bet right now During that tournament it would
have been like one to like like one trillion There was no
like no chance I should have won this
Like I legitimately thought Bravo DMed SK and was like can
you please let her have just one game like During like the
first set like I was like I was like I was originally
thought bravo dmsk and was like can she have like one round
off you just one round and i thought that like i just
thought that's what happened and then when i won the second
round i was like this is real
i was like oh my god this is real and then i remember the
casters were like did doki give her controller to bravo what
the fuck is going on Like, which stage I'm team is SC
rooting for before I bet.
And SC, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Even the casters were like, oh my God.
Did they give the controller to Bra Pro?
There's no way Doki's playing like this.
Even I did, I don't know what, I had the spirit of King in
me.
I took control of my body.
Just let it rip.
Yeah.
And I ended with the alley kicks.
The one move, Brawl Pro.
Coach Brawl Pro told me never to use in the competition.
But I was like, but it works, though.
They never expect the alley kicks.
They never do.
Because it's so fucking stupid.
Like, who would use it?
That's when you know the controller was in my...
hands my signature move alley kicks like no one ever expects
the alley kicks so for anyone out let me see i know someone
made a i know someone made a clip of this of this moment uh
so if you guys want to relive it uh it paid off it really
did they never expect the third fourth and fifth alley
I always find that one move that no one ever expects every
character I play there's always that one move no one will
ever expect me expect that person to use because it's so
fucking stupid or dumb and I know because they don't expect
it because they're like any sane player will not use this
move and I'm not a sane player.
player.
There's always a dokey move.
Husky, they're giving the super chat.
Thank you.
The spirit of king taking over.
For a moment, it's your earliest point of being an honorary
Mexican.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
guys i what are you gonna do do a wake-up it's like that
green goblin mask is like you should do the green do a
wake-up three feet they'll never expect it do another alley
kick they'll never expect it they're never gonna expect the
fourth alley kick come on do it i'm the mask i i'm literally
the the green goblin mask you know you want to do it um
anyway uh wake up d i know one that is ever ready for it
level three i'll wake up do it um anyway so there's also
another interesting thing in that locker and it's like it's
a metal you might not notice it because it's like uh just a
front view But if you are at Offkai, uh, uh, if you are at
Offkai, uh, there is a medal in there.
Uh, and, uh, that is the very first Twitch rivals I've ever
won in, in back all the way since in my corporate days.
So they sent us Twitch rival medals for any teams.
a streamer that won first place in any other tournaments and
um i won't say which game it is because it was like back
then but this was the very first twitch rivals i've ever won
and uh they sent us a medal for it and i figured like you
guys could see that in person the first uh not the minecraft
one the minecraft one i wanted like as jokie um so i figured
i'd give you guys an opportunity to see it in person to see
like the real medal itself because sometimes you know a lot
of people never seen the medal before never seen it in
person because not a lot of streamers have like um shown it
before or like shown the what they receive so that's what it
is right there uh in the locker so it was the very first
twitch rivalries i've ever won um and uh you get to see that
in person too all right anyway now the thing that everyone
wants me to talk about for last.
I'm gonna edge you guys.
Now it's the important stuff.
Wish I'll show last.
Fair.
Alright, don't worry.
It'll be quick.
It's a wild thing.
section by the way that's a wild section over there above me
so obviously i had to include the dog shirt so this is the
very first sample of the original dog shirt that i own um
it's not one of the replication replica dog shirts you know
the one sold in the public this was the very first sample of
the dog shirt the very like like dog shirt number one that
was sent like that was sent to So, um, so, so, I had to, I
had to put that in my locker.
Yeah, the OG, yeah, dog shirt prime.
The ultimate dog shirt of all dog shirts.
The very first one made of a lot of them.
So many dog shirts.
And the next to it is a Nessie hat that I bought during my
very first I've ever been to in my life so this was the one
in Sapporo in Japan Sapporo I think also two years ago or a
year I don't remember it's been so long but was it a year
ago or two years it was a year ago sorry a year ago the very
first land I've ever been to in my life and I I also brought
like stuff I like places like lands I've been to as well you
will see when I go scroll down the lockers so I bought that
boat the the little hat there when i was there the one the
winter yeah in january um so um that's the hat i bought uh
during the apex saporo land and it was the very first sign
i've ever been to so that's the story behind that anyway so
all right and then this is the bottom the bottom layer uh
marriage what did i actually click i actually clicked that
okay um the bottom there all right also another nesty
plushie because i was like yeah nesty because apex was a
huge part of my life uh so i figured to include a bunch of
apex stuff so down there that's actually desk mac i own i
it's i don't use it anymore because um um it's dirty
but um so but i did wash it i did wash it but i also like to
when it's dirty i need i want to have like another desk mat
to use and usually like after i wash it i don't like i don't
use it i don't really use it again only because i was like
oh i already used i'm already have a new desk mat on my
table and uh and so i'm just too lazy to to like swap it
back so that is like one of the desk mat i own it's like a
pokemon um like pokemon asana desk mat and i love this
artist i own a lot of their desk mat i have an anima
crossing i have several other And right now, I'm using the
one where Pokemon is at an amusement park, Desmat.
But it's one of my favorite artists for Desmat.
Because I just love all the little details in it.
So I brought that from home.
And it's also another Nessie Plushie.
I think that is exclusive to last year's Sapporo Land.
So I think this Color Barret, you can only...
I don't remember it was this one.
I think it was the pink one.
I don't remember it.
But this is one of the Nessies you can get at the Sapporo
Land.
And in the back...
very hard to see but the back you might see like the little
shape like in the very back there's like writing in the back
um that was um actually the fair i showed a picture of this
on twitter before but that was the very first marvel rivals
land that i went to uh that net ease invited me to in guanjo
and that is an autograph uh banner of the team that won
first place in the very first marvel rivals land with rad
esports so like trust me level one crook like i played with
these players too like later on down in the line so it's a
fully autographed uh banner um that like when we go there
like when we were at the land um they gave us like cheer at
sharing banners for teams we were we want to root for and um
the entire rat team that won first place of their very first
land signed it for me so that's displayed at afkai too so
it's like you guys can see that in person like stuff i own
like i said like i like collecting a lot of things right now
i like collecting autographs from cool like people i meet
and everything um so there is that finally All right.
All right.
For the main show.
The section everyone has been waiting for for me to talk
about.
Captain.
Welcome to Tomato Farm.
Welcome.
All right.
It's fine.
The main show.
The star of the show, might I add.
The sacred text.
So we'll go left to right.
will save the best for last so the left side that is my
mouse my game one of my gaming mouse like i love logitech
it's one of my like a gopro g pro wireless i um i always use
logitech for my mice for my gaming mouse um slayer welcome
to tomato farm welcome welcome and uh so um on the left is a
customized, uh, I always have them customized too.
There's the, the one I have right now, the Super Strike,
which is like the best mouse, um, in the industry right now,
um, uh, that one's not customized because it's so hard to
get.
I don't think it's easier to get now because like, when it
first came out, it was so hard to get the Super Strike.
So I couldn't get a customized version of it just cause it
was so difficult to get your hands on it.
I had to, I had to preorder back order i had to pre-order a
back order of this of the super strike mouse so i it's not
the one i have that i'm using right now is just the default
version it's not customized or anything it's just the
version that you get when you buy it just because it's so
hard to to own one um a couple of months ago um um anyway so
usually when i i order when i buy um buy a new gaming mouse
i buy a customized gaming mouse in terms of like colors and
stuff.
I don't really care about like the functionality.
Like I care about the functionality.
That's why I own a Logitech mouse.
It's why I own like a G Pro Wireless.
This one, G Pro Wireless, I use Wireless Mouse too.
And I just like having it look match my setup and
everything.
So this one is one of my
Logitech mice that, uh, got, and so it's, like, customized
to, like, my colors and everything, so that's what it is,
um, and I, it's one of my older ones.
Um, I have a lot of them.
I have, like, I think I have three customized mice, um, you
know, because, like, every time they, they release a new
one, I order a new customized mice, um, you know, because it
enhances my performance and everything.
All right, anyway, next one is the, uh, minions, so why
Kristoff that I bought at New York Comic-Con.
Dubey was there when I bought it.
So, it was when I was invited by Capcom to test out their
games at New York City.
And I figured, why not?
Why not?
And I asked if Dubey wants to come along too, because I got
an invitation to New York Comic-Con.
And this was one of the few things.
I bought, I didn't buy a lot of stuff, surprisingly, I
didn't buy a lot of stuff at New York Comic-Con.
But when I saw the Savoski minions, Krista, at the Savoski
booth at Comic-Con, I had to get it.
I had to own it.
Because I thought it was so funny.
I don't see and then dubby was like why don't you get the
Minecraft one and I was like dubby you should get the
Minecraft one because there was like the pig the Minecraft
pig I was like dubby you should get the Minecraft pig I was
trying I was like the devil on her shoulder I was like oh my
god you should get the Minecraft pig and she's like I don't
know shit I was like you should get it it's good it's so
funny you should totally she didn't get it though my it
didn't work on her like I was trying to peer pressure I was
like it's so funny like oh my god you know you want it by
the Minecraft pig Sawaski Krista anyway so I just thought it
was so funny and I was like I had to own it um uh is that
the legendary yaoi has seen the picture don't give you
simple mind it thank you in the super chat thank you thank
don't worry we're saving the best for last it's the sacred
yes it is the sacred text but I'll say I'll talk about it
last because all like it's the main event um that everyone
wants me to talk about the the elephant in the in the locker
room uh you know how live and waiting for this oh if i make
a name for yourself here don't keep cyber thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you addressed me
um anyway um so that is like i remember mousy was like like
she was looking at a pair of She was looking at the Swaski
website and she saw the minions collab and she was like who
is this for Who is the target audience for the Swaski
minions crystal and then and then because and I was like I'm
the target Because they were asking for those who didn't
watch the bond of the announcement and we're talking about
what we had in lockers I was like yeah, I brought my Swaski
crystal minions and I was like oh my god, you're the target
audience for this It was me like who would buy that I would
buy it so um anyway now the thing behind the minions Swahski
crystal is the infamous confessional booth that I have on my
table every time I do something
So that if I ever do anything If I ever do anything That
requires me to confess At least I'll be forgiven With my
portable confessional booth Where if you press it There will
be a light that turns on And it'll be like You are forgiven
Also the funniest thing is that I did not tell them how to
display this this is what the this is where the staff they
the staff themselves were the ones that decorated this
locker so like I put it in my bag like I put it in the bag
where I gave them all the stuff so they were the ones that
arranged everything so they know they they know where to put
that i didn't give any instructions on how to arrange the
lockers
they know ball yeah they they had to put it next to the
dogen and now that i've talked about the confessional booth
The infamous confessional booth that I have on my table
Because I thought it was so funny That you can buy a
portable confessional booth And then whenever you press it,
it will shout out You are forgiven
So it'll forgive me for the sins I commit Every minute
It's time to address the elephant in the locker So for those
who don't know know for those who don't know this is the
sacred text the the the bible
the the dojin that everyone wanted to know about wanted to
hear more about
this was the very first and last Dojin I've ever bought
because I was the original sin because I was so desperate
to for any content of my rare pair back in the day so I was
so desperate to just have any content of this rare pair from
dynasty warriors
i i had a fate like there was only like uh like i can only
count on one hand how many artists would draw artwork of
this pairing and like to a point where like and i found
their like secret tumblr blog where they post a wild artwork
and I found out and then I found out they were selling
dogeins they were selling a dogein of this rare pair and
like I think she was like one of the two artists that would
draw the real wild the spicy stuff like like like like So,
so I was just like, I must own it because I was so desperate
for any content of this pairing because this was my only
rare pair that I liked.
And I was not used to having, I was not used to having a
pairing that has absolutely no content or like any content.
at all it is not english it is in japanese um i was so
thirsty i was so thirsty for any content um because i'm i'm
so used to being so well fed and like just having a like a
full stomach of all my other pairings like i i would read
anything read any fanfic look at any artwork if it meant
that I could consume more content of my rare pairing.
I was in a desert.
I felt like I was in a desert that finally, finally a drop
of rain, like a one drop, like a cup of water suddenly
showed up.
I was so hungry and thirsty.
I...
I even went to Pixiv.
Is that how I pronounce it?
Pixiv or Pixiv?
I went to Pixiv.
And back when it was like very, not Pixiv wasn't very well
known on NNA.
But like, it was the only way for, like I was trying to find
the Japanese tags of this pairing.
I like discovered the tags, the Japanese tags for this
pairing and went on Pixiv.
to find artwork you guys need a lobe this is like more than
eight plus years ago
i was so down like picks it back then was not very well
known back then like in the in na in america in america it
was not very well known like i dug like i discovered i well
i didn't discover it but found out about Pixiv and I found
like I went I went full I'm reformed by the way I I'm
reformed now so um I yeah um yeah and I found the tags just
to have to consume more content I was I you don't understand
I was so starving I've never been not fed and like i never
been like i never experienced that before because all my
other pairings back in the day when i was um an ex-fujo i
would have so much content i would be i would be like in a
in a five-star hotel every day every day there would be new
content of it and i never experienced some a rare pairing
until that day um of of this couple of sima dao and juge don
So, it's in practically mint condition.
By the way, it's practically in mint condition.
I even, it still, it still has the postcard slash artwork
that was an exclusive postcard that got from their very
first release of this Dojin.
um so you see at the bottom of on the on the the locker
thing you see the postcard that included to show that it was
like the first release of it it's not like a re-release so
um it was the first release of it and why that pairing i
really love dana see uh
uh it was collaboration over because they saw my my my boy
love dogen um michael jackson they go super chat thank you
thank you um because i love i love dynasty warriors and when
i played the game when these two characters were introduced
in the dynasty warriors game i don't remember which game it
was i was like oh my god i see it i see the oh my the
tension the sexual tension between those two there i i that
is my otp that is my otp in that game right now in the
dynasty warriors franchise that is my one true pairing
i was like that right there that's who i'll die for
The vision.
I see the vision.
So, so that's why.
Anyway, so.
Anyway, I ordered it.
I ordered it online with my mom's credit card.
With my mom's credit card.
Congo thinking of a super chat thinking thing.
You know, the practical practically is doing a lot of it.
be lifting um and um i remember when i first received it and
then the thing is um i moved a lot i move around a lot uh
holy shit i move around a lot so this dojin was in storage
for a very long time and it was packed up in a box for a
very very long time you know through eight years it's been
like me eight plus years i don't even know if it's eight
years i think it's been more than eight years so it's been
like packed up in a box and i didn't know where it was i
know you guys were like always like can we see it can we see
the doge and i was like i don't know where it is guys i
legitimately don't know where it is anymore um because it's
like somewhere in one of those boxes but i don't know where
i put it i don't know where i packed it up because i you
know i don't unpack anything
Because you guys were like, can you show us like a picture
of it?
Can we see a picture of this dogen?
Like, oh, what is it about?
What is the title called?
And I was like, I don't know, guys.
I legitimately don't know.
I don't remember.
So, like, we will always hear, like, the stories about this
dogen that the first and last dogen I ever owned.
And, uh, it's like, it's like a myth, you know?
It's like, does Doki actually own this?
Like, it's like lost media.
media and and I think a couple of weeks before the Korea
trip I was trying to find something I don't remember what I
was trying to find I don't remember what I was searching for
I did this was the doge and you've been searching for it but
I remember what it was but one of those boxes when I was
like trying oh it was when I bought my new bed.
Oh my god, I remember now.
It was when I bought my new bed because I was using one of
the boxes I have as like, um, as like a, uh, what was it
called?
Like a bed counter, like a bed shelf.
I don't know what's the call when you have like a little,
um, countertop or whatever next to your bed so i so what is
it called the the table the bedside table yes okay so a
nightstand the nightstand so when i first moved to this uh
apartment um i needed a nightstand and i was just like i'm
just gonna use one of these boxes as a nightstand because
and I forgot I forgot about it I just treated as a
nightstand bedside table like a nightstand so this giant box
um that was next to me whenever I sleep and then when the
new bed came in because I upgraded to a king-size bed um
because I was just like you know I had this old bed for
years like five plus years I should but finally get a new
bed and I upgraded to a It wasn't gonna fit if I had the
giant box next to it.
Always by my side.
Yes, it was always by my side all along.
Wishing me good night, like giving me the sweet dreams.
I was sleeping.
I never opened it.
I was like, I need a box because I don't unpack anything
because I'm like, this is not where I wanna live
permanently.
I wanna actually own a place to finally unpack everything
because I was just so tired.
of packing, unpacking, packing, unpacking, packing,
unpacking.
So I only unpack the most necessary items, like my PC set up
and everything.
I only unpack the most necessary things I need.
So, and I keep everything packed up.
So when I finally move to a permanent place, I'll never have
to unpack again.
Because I move around so much.
I've been renting for like a lot, half my life.
so like more than half my life i've been renting and moving
around so much like i've been i think i've been to like
seven plus i've been to seven plus different um i lived in
seven plus different places growing up so i was just so
tired like it's like you know the first time you know um
it's like you know yeah i want to keep it more personal and
blah blah but then it started getting so tiring like
unpacking and packing started being so exhausting that i
just gave up of doing that so um so anyway uh i finally i we
i had to move that the my giant box that i was using as a
nightstand table bedside table and i was trying to move the
box out of the room and i find i was like what is this box
what is this and i finally opened it and the the first thing
i saw was the dojin and i was Oh my God.
The fabled sacred text.
It's no longer lost media.
There it is.
The Holy Bible.
The myth.
From the dokeybird streams.
The Holy Grail.
Preserved in ice.
I was like, that's where it's been this entire time.
That's where it was.
And I was like, I have to put this in the locker.
I have, this has to go to Korea.
So, So that is the story of the first and last dojin I've
ever owned.
Yeah, I got to share it to the world.
Now, all the random, like, people, random YouTuber fans at
Off Guy who have never heard of me before or who don't watch
me.
And they seem like everyone else's lockers are very normal.
Compare them.
Like, I mean, essentially, they're, like, compare to mine.
And then they see my locker.
And it's just yowie.
It's just right there.
Front and center.
Yowie.
All those people who might not know who I am.
It'd be like, they'll see.
R18 yowie.
Like, and the crystal minion right beside it.
and the crystal minion.
I saw some people tweet out, like, because they're like, oh,
oh my god, my oh, she's locker, like, you know, and they're
like, what the fuck?
They're like, what the fuck?
What the fuck is the Sudoku's locker?
Because they don't know the story.
They don't know the Dojin story.
They were not there for for that story.
So it's like their first impression of me.
What a way to introduce myself.
Because in the other lockers, there's like other stuff.
Like, you know, they have like, you know, Marin was like
Pikmin.
They're like Pikmin there.
And then Mousy has like Madoka.
And then Amalie had like, you know, characters.
She's voice acted and stuff like that.
And K-pop Demon Hunters.
And my locker.
and then not just not just like fucking vanilla shit full on
R18 Yowie and a minion and a Swaski minion crystal right
flashbang Yowie
how do you not dart your eyes into that i'm bringing the
wild and wild card club you guys and then one of my favorite
things about it is that they gave us a list of like okay
these are the things we're going to include in your lot like
these is the finalized list that we're going to include in
the locker and i love over here was these are this is what
the staff wrote to like categorize my dogen and they wrote
favorite manga volumes copy and the hashtag is like the
picture of and if you click on the hashtag it's the picture
of the dogen it's I didn't write that by the way they wrote
that in the list of items of like what would be included in
the what would be included in the locker and i was like
favorite manga volumes i don't remember right putting like
wait what did they i was like because i saw the list so they
want to make sure like everything i want they want to make
sure that these are uh i approved the things in my locker so
and then i was just so confused when i when i was going
through the list um and included pictures of it and i had to
click on it to see the picture like and so i for my favorite
manga volumes i i was like so i was like huh what did they
put in what did they put in there and i clicked on it and i
just see the yaoi dogen and i was like because i was like oh
my god i wonder if it's i wonder if it's death note i wonder
they oh did they buy death note manga for me because i put
that down because they're like what's your favorite manga
what's your favorite manga volumes and i wrote down in there
i was like oh if you could include death note manga It's one
of my first like it was the or Hitalia It was the what first
thing one of the first mongas I've ever read and it's my
favorite anime slash manga series ever So I thought it was
death note Yeah I just I thought it was death note because I
put it and I wrote it down And so and I clicked on it It was
full on two guys making out And I was like, oh, that's what,
what, oh, that's what it is.
That's what it is.
I would have loved that they included Italia stuff because
like I did write that down.
Um, in the, I did write that down, um, in the, the list of
stuff I wanted to include it.
Obviously this was very limited.
I think like they saved a lot of money because they didn't
have to buy it.
anything for me except for the faker plush because all the
other there's lockers they have to buy stuff to recreate the
vision that the other girls had but i was just like i'll
just i i just want to bring like personal like a lot of my
personal items to decorate the locker because i don't know
when i'll have another chance to do something like that
where you guys can actually see all these items that i talk
about on stream so they saved a lot of money by not spending
money on my locker
so so they saved a lot of money for my locker
um um but yeah uh that was that's the story of the lockers
my locker uh that's at off guy me thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you cute gift uh rally waving them
waving looking down suspiciously.
Thank you for the...
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
But yeah, I finally talked about the locker.
Finally, guys get to see it.
So congratulations to all the dragoons who are there who get
to see it in person at Off Guy.
It must be a very surreal experience to finally be the...
see all those items up close and everything.
Oh yeah, alright.
So I saw some dragons are asking me to talk about the story
Um about bumping into snuffy during the tour So um While we
were setting up Uh where my staff was setting up the tour
for the wildcard club To for me to show me around Um and
stuff Uh Let me hydrate real quick
At the Noms Cafe booth Um Anyway so Apparently, Snuffy was
there, like, doing a virtual tour on stream as well.
And then I could sort of hear her, but we were having
internet connections.
We were having, like, bad internet, because, and I also saw
Gina, too.
So, the internet was really, really bad.
So I could, like, sort of see her, but it was, like,
lagging.
But then I did see the wizard next to the person holding
Snuffy's camera.
because like we haven't fully finished setting up yet we
were still like doing tech text like tech technical stuff
trying to set up um yeah so i saw the wizard next to her and
i was so confused i was like oh my god it's a wizard and
then i couldn't really hear what snuffy was saying i put up
stuffy stream because that's the great thing about being
virtual just back in store i didn't really understand
because like you know i was getting like feed like i was
trying it was just loud ganked on my end from the discord
call so like there was like feedback from there but I I saw
myself on her stream and I could see that they she did not
hear what I was saying because I was lagging and I couldn't
really hear what she was saying because she was lagging too
so what I didn't realize was she hides and then she DMed me
she DMed me and was like um
to play as me at Off-Kai.
And to laugh at me as me at Off-Kai.
So, because I was like, what the fuck is this wizard doing
here?
So she fucking hired a fucking mall Santa actor to role play
as her, as a wizard.
And I don't know if she posted a photo bit let me see i make
a pretty sure i can grab a screenshot from i'm pretty sure
she tweeted it out or some i oh she didn't okay let me um
let me go find uh yeah like i i didn't realize it was a
fucking that's so smart that's so funny like she's so funny
fucking spawning in a pal world as grandpa like just just
doing like like she's doing like role play and just random
shit like she's so good at role-playing guys I'm so jealous
like she is a she is a she is so good at role-playing I wish
I like like she's always larping somehow it's like she's at
a Renaissance fair
all right so I'm trying to second get just just him all
right yeah so she hired a Ma Santa um to do like snuffy meet
and greets you know like so like she's meeting all her fans
so funny she's meeting all her fans as snuffy yeah
um with the Ma Santa so that's how she was doing her meet
and greets which is so funny it's it's it's so funny
thinking about it like that's just brilliant um so creative
so this is snuffy's physical form um that's your physical
form in and you can see in the back uh you can see that i'll
show you as this too so you're like that's just a wizard
That's just an old man in a wizard costume.
No, you don't understand.
There's layers to this.
This is what it looks like in the back There's layers to
this guys Just
Is that yeah,
oh my god
God, that is Snuffy!
So, yeah, so the Jesus freaking genius.
Yeah, so it might actually be Snuffy.
Yeah, so, anyway.
Um, I meant, I meant, I meant Snuffy the Wizard there.
I didn't realize that that was her.
her that was supposed to be her like i said i was lagging so
we were in the middle of fixing the technical issues with
the internet and everything because we had to connect to a
different uh router um so after she left everything was
fixed uh it's just a regular wizard snuffy the wizard he had
three raccoons in the wizard costume yeah no that is her
Like his day job Guys, guys He can't be Maw Santa For the
entire year What is he gonna do in the summer?
He had During the summer he's snuffy On Christmas he's Santa
But during the summer He's a raccoon Guys, thank you for the
super chat Thank you, thank you He can't be Santa all year
long Guys, what do you think The Maw Sanas do when it's not
The holidays
you're worried about few gray hair snuffy seems to be fully
gray already it suits her really well thank you for the
super chat thank you yeah her day job is being santa on
christmas
anyway uh
um and that's that's really that's really a store like so
far the at the moment at off guy yeah true have you seen
Santa and stuffy at the same place huh I don't think so a
dream thank you in a super chat thank you thank oh my god
wait but that's before the panel we got extend we gotta send
Earth's lifespan for one more day yes what else oh yeah
there was one thing I wanted to talk about that I really
wanted to talk about because I thought it was I thought it
was okay I didn't think it was okay it's not really funny
because when I say it you guys are like oh you think that
okay but I didn't realize this and I was like oh my god how
did I not realize this speaking on a topic of snuffy I'm
going to talk about my little pony now
I'm going to talk about my little pony Because they recently
announced, for those who don't know, San Diego Comic-Con is
going on right now.
And for those who don't know about Comic-Con, this is when
they do all the announcements of all the announcements that
is related in gaming, voice acting, animation, movies,
whatever.
So that's where they do the reveals and stuff.
So they finally revealed that they are rebooting, uh, was it
Gen 4 or whatever the fuck?
Uh, is Gen 6?
I don't know.
I don't... Oh, Gen 4.
Uh, they're rebooting Gen 4 of My Little Pony.
Um, and, um, so it's like the one that everyone likes.
Uh, and what's funny, I thought about, I thought how funny
it was.
So it's like Gen 6 is practically the reboot of Gen 4.
And I thought that they literally deleted apple jack and
rarity from the show they just they don't exist anymore
they're not in this universe in the reboot because they
don't sell enough toys because they are the i didn't realize
this they were the least popular members in the in the in
the my little pony franchise so they're just God, they never
existed.
What?
Yeah.
They're just, God, just like that.
So, like, the main six is now the four.
Yeah, because they're not popular enough.
Popular enough.
toy sales
yeah yeah so and if you guys didn't know so you know like
Twilight Sparkles, Cutie Mark the purple one they it's like
they all kept the same symbol like Cutie Marks are the
symbols on their butts by the way so um if you look at the
stars on her butt her fucking uh uh I guess tramp stamp but
for ponies uh You can see the stars right here.
You see that?
Originally, on her butt, it's the little sparkle stars.
There were five around it.
So they literally deleted the two stars on her butt because
they no longer exist.
They...
They ceased to exist in her universe.
They removed the two stars That represented Rarity and
Applejack on her ass.
And they actually...
Yeah, it's gone.
That's crazy.
They are erased from the multiverse.
They erased the existence.
Thanos visited the pony world.
Yeah.
That's so dark.
So...
Also, another funny thing is the one of the, I don't know if
they're like the, what's it called?
When someone, when someone who are like headline
spearheading the project, there's a word for it.
What's the word for it?
Like the person that spearheading the project or like the
director of the project, there's a specific word for it in
animation.
I don't remember what that word is.
Yeah, it's called Friendship Forever.
Yeah, because there's four of them.
The Showrunners, yes.
So one of the creative directors slash Showrunners.
So it's like there's two of them.
But I thought it was so funny.
But yeah, this is called Friendship Forever because there's
four of them, right?
Get it?
Apparently not forever for Applejack or Rarity.
Friendship was not forever for them.
Yeah, who needs honesty and generosity anyway?
That is true.
They represent honesty and generosity.
That is so true.
Like,
I'll cast, thank you in the super chat.
Thank you.
See, it wouldn't work.
The show has got friendship forever.
And if there's six of them, it wouldn't be clever.
You get me?
Like, friendship doesn't sell toys.
That's true.
What's good is friendship.
monetize it.
So anyway, one of the showrunners, I love his art, but like
this is sort of his reputation.
One of the showrunners is that guy that also was one of the
creative directors for the reboot of Spyro.
But before he was in charge of the reboot of Spyro, he was
very good at drawing beefy dragons.
beefy furry dragons you know that guy you know what i'm
talking about that artist he was very before before the he
blew like but he was known like he was known as a they got
him as a creative director for the spy room but you know
that guy right you remember that guy that artist he was very
and he designed several of the dragons he was like one of
the guys he was the creative director and he design several
of the rebooted dragon like the dragons the dragon elders um
from the reboot of the spiral and you can when you see the
spiral elder elders you're like yeah that was drawn by a
furry you know like if you look at the design you're like
that guy that was definitely designed by a furry you know
what I'm saying like
I thought it was funny that he like also is This guy, this
guy This artist And also he's the creative director of
Bandicoots too This guy
Because I remember Like I remember like when Spyro was
rebooted I looked at his profile because I really liked his
I really liked the Spyro art style I didn't not clicking
that because i saw this and i was like oh that looks sick
yeah um like this artwork but he also designed like these
are look at that just look at this and tell me look at this
and look at that dragon and tell me that wasn't designed by
a guy
know what they want um but anyway um that's like the one of
the showrunner one of the showrunners uh of uh um of the new
my little pony series anyway this is sort of a bit off topic
but also related to my little pony because everyone's
talking about my little pony right now because of the uh you
know uh because of the whole thing and then i saw a comment
button i was like what and they're like someone was like
quote retweeted and was like i bet you she got canceled like
i bet you the reason why they didn't include rarity is
because she definitely caught cancelled for being a racist.
So, and I was just like, what?
wait, Rarity was a racist?
So, I forgot about this, because I haven't watched My Little
Pony a long ass time.
Like, I used to watch it when the show first came out.
way to the end and then I only rewatched it once because I
actually some of the storyline like I liked the music and
some of the storylines I thought was for like I like
animation so I'm a huge animation fan and one of those shows
I love rewatching animation stuff so and I did enjoy some of
the stories and uh these songs from it and um so I was like
rarity was a racist I don't remember It was where, you
know...
It was a screenshot of how she was trying to turn this other
species.
It's like, you're not beautiful unless you look like a pony.
And...
Yeah.
Yeah, and so I forgot about that.
I forgot that, like, one time there was a song where she was
singing to another species of animal.
I was telling her she gotta look like more of a pony Because
you're not beautiful You will not fit in Unless you look and
sound like a pony And I was like Oh my god And then And
there were other scenes in there And I was like Oh my god
Wait And then there was other screenshots of it.
I just thought it was so fun.
Yeah, that's like yeah, she's and then and then there was
other screenshots where it's like I don't socialize with
dragons and
I was like, oh my god the writers made her a racist and I
never realized I
that's so wild yeah this is I didn't realize that oh no
that's evil rarity yeah that's it's all a joke by the way
and she's just mean and it's and she is just mean But that
way, that's an evil alternative reality when she's allowed
to be.
Yeah, this is all a joke.
I'm not implying that she is a racist.
But I was just like, I thought that was so funny.
Because I was like, oh my God, I never got on to the fact
that sometimes she says some wild things in the show.
Yeah.
I was like, oh my God.
Wait, I never realized.
that
Brady got cancelled I, I, yeah so, um so I thought it was
like, it just it was just like, it was so funny to see all
the screenshots because I was just like I didn't realize the
writers accidentally made it seem like she was racist but
it's just the fact that she was like that's not Couture or
whatever the fuck But for some reason, she's like, also said
it about, like, other species.
So it makes her look so bad.
Harmony, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
This is another one.
So this is another screenshot that people were showing right
here.
When she told a zebra that she looks terrible.
Terrible because she has stripes like
She she is direct by the way she is directing that at a
zebra
Will you cut that down just look at the stripes so garish
What did Applejack do she's in sell unfortunately Yeah
I read So
So I was just like Oh my god I didn't I didn't even realize
that I didn't realize the writers Accidentally might have
made her Slightly racist Well it was very slow
Pardon But I was just like, what?
Anyway, that's just a joke.
They didn't cancel her because of it.
I just thought that was like, like a funny tweet.
Because I was like, what?
Like, what do you mean about?
This is a children's show.
What do you mean?
Like, I'm like, what do you mean?
Like, and I looked.
at it like they were at a compilation and i was just like oh
my god that did happen that that did happen uh oh wait look
at this quote
this is one of an official panel from the comic series by
the way this is one of the official panels from the comic
series.
You know, he's rather handsome for non-pony, isn't he?
Like...
Oh, don't...
The Google Dockey.
I can see it.
I can see the Google Dockey.
Whoa, Rarity!
Bro!
Damn!
Are you being non-pony?
What do you mean by that?
She really just said that.
Anyway, that's why I wanted to talk to you.
about uh dear oh dear oh no i just i was like i thought
about it because i know like i was thinking about like the
snuffy conversation made me remember about the my little
pony reboot i was like oh yeah that's going on right now uh
outcast thank you with a super chat thank you thank you um
She will not be missed.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Anyway, that's really all I want to talk about today.
I mean,
that's really all I have to talk about today.
But it's great hanging out with you guys.
Today, I was, like I said, I just wanted to talk.
I just wanted to yapp.
I didn't really want to play any games.
I didn't really want to do a game, really.
I just wanted to hang out and yapp and just talk about
random shit in my mind.
And I had a great time.
I hope you guys enjoyed the two-hour yapp session today.
I know.
When one of my VTuber played videos.
You remember when Doki used to play video games?
It's been so long.
I don't even think I could remember the last game she
played.
when my when my when she was a game when she was a gamer
bird what happened to that
um anyway gaming tomorrow though we're gaming tomorrow don't
worry gaming is back um but i hope you guys enjoyed hanging
out with me guys um and i had a great time uh just chilling
uh being my eepy sleepy self and um just yapping all these
tangents today um i hope any of all the dragons who are at
afka are having great time there and all the dragons that
are at teko had a great time there too it's great meeting
all the dragons at teko i'm gonna be meet some more dragons
tomorrow at afka as well um for those who are watching and
are at off guy you can be um you can enter the lottery to
meet me at off guy if i have any purchase at the nom's cafe
booth and they do the lottery draw tomorrow so you purchased
anything on friday uh you might have already entered the
lottery but if you want if you're uh you haven't yet uh and
you want to meet me just purchase any item at nom's cafe
booth and and they'll do a lottery draw for a potential to
meet me uh tomorrow um anyway guys uh as Always everybody,
stay hydrated, posture check, get up and move around to get
that blood flowing.
And if you stay up for me, head to bed because you deserve
it.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Oh yeah, and we upload a new long form video on my channel,
guys.
Please check it out.
Long form content is still being worked on.
Still trial period right now to figure out who to get for
who to get as the main editor.
So please check out the new video.
a new editor so please check it out um and this one is a
compilation video so yeah give that a view it helps the
channel a lot helps the algorithm a lot um give that video a
like hit that bell button for make sure to hit that bell
button for notifications uh make sure to give a comment a
like on the video and everything it really does mean a lot
um but yeah um hey guys i'll see you guys Bye!